in The Witcher 3 one of the most
important tools you have at your
disposal are Geralt potions while
they're not necessary to your survival
in the beginning of the game they become
much more vital as you progress so it's
a good idea to start farming for their
crafting ingredients early
fortunately the games first area white
orchard is a great place to start
stockpiling in the beginning of the game
you have the ability to craft only four
potions swallow cat thunderbolt and
white honey swallow is a potion that
accelerates your vitality regeneration
cat lets you see in the dark and is
handy during the night or in dark areas
filled with dangerous creatures Thunder
ball creases your attack power for an
added defensive edge in combat and white
honey clears your body of all toxicity
and cancels all active potion effects
little more on that later so how do you
make potions
well potions require three kinds of
ingredients the most essential of these
ingredients are herbs which are found
all around the environment as rule of
thumb you should always collect as many
as possible a great place to get a whole
bunch in white or treat it just outside
the herbalist college though if you ever
need specific herbs such as some
honeysuckle for the white honey potion
you can always buy them from the
herbalist as well the second type of
ingredient you need to craft a potion is
alcohol a consistent ingredient that
appears in all the potions I mentioned
earlier is dwarven spirit you can
usually find some in smuggler caches and
treasure chests scattered around the map
they can also be bought from any white
orchard merchants but a smart thing to
do is to buy a crafting manuscript from
the herbalist so you can make your own
for much cheaper the third type of
ingredient that appears in potion
crafting recipes is moths through body
parts these require some time to get
since you can't really find a place to
buy them in the beginning the big one
you need in white orchard though are
drowner brains for the swallow potion
drowners are the blue humanoid sea
monster folk that are usually found near
water common locations in white orchard
include the southern shore line near the
ransac village the swamp lands to the
south of the nilfgaardian garrison and
along the shoreline to the left of the
Ford signpost knowing those essential
ingredients you should be good to start
making potions but before you do there
are a couple of important things to keep
in mind each potion has something called
a toxicity amount taking a potion will
contribute this amount to Gerald's
overall toxicity level which totals at
100 so always be mindful of how many
potions you consume
lastly when you successfully craft a
potion you typically get a stock of
three what you made you meditate and
have any kind of hard liquor in your
inventory any stock of potions you have
will fully replenish absolutely make
sure to do this whenever you can so you
don't have to farm all those crafting
materials again I hope this helps you on
your ways you continue to play through
and explore the world of The Witcher 3
Wild Hunt